it turns out that the only way that a
cultural group can motivate women to
have children is by forcing them then
the only cultural groups that exist in
the future will be the cultural groups
that Force women to have children and
this is something we're increasingly
seeing in places like China you know if
if we see society today as Alliance of
disperate cultural groups and we're
asking why do so few people have
children today the dominant cultural
group we call that's the urban
monoculture it's a culture that's in
London New York all over the world today
it controls our media controls our
centers of power it tells people do what
you want be who you want search for your
happiness and your purpose in the world
but it doesn't tell people to sacrifice